Schweck du Homo first!
Schweck du Homo
40 klingt so gewollt und nicht gekonnt
Wenn einer wenn einer geschrieben hätte hey, ihr geilen super agilen cloud native
Poggers keckweights sonst was dann hätte ich mich angesprochen gefühlt ja
Gar kein peps mehr
Sprich angesprochen okay das mag ja ich weiß jetzt nicht ob sie bait ist oder oder ernsthaft aber hey
Ich meine ich finde es ja gut da hat es zumindest die die wirkung nicht ganz
verfehlt
Der aufzählungspunkt links ist ja was macht denn der da eigentlich
Es hat html ich mein hey guck mal die machen fenster die machen kein html
Auch kein windows painz champions ich weiß sehr oxy nur dankeschön für den sap
was
Was ist denn jetzt los
Warum will das java
Das kommt mir eigentlich normalerweise nicht auf system drauf
Android ach das ist wegen android ah verstehe
Ok das leuchtet das leuchtet ein
Oh mist ich muss den preisschirm neu starten das habe ich ja komplett vergessen da ist ja immer noch procken
Der schon seit letzten drei tagen procken
Vielleicht sollte ich mal einbauen dass er sich nachts automatisch neu starten also
Der katz geht's gut
Ok ja standard ja war alles gut yes
Excellent
Ja aber bald muss ich nicht ich habe jetzt runtergestellt wie oft er abfragt
und
Ich werde jetzt nicht mal so oft geplockt ich kann das sogar ein paar tage anlassen
Ja ich sie leid ich habe keine ahnung ich habe flatter noch nie verwendet
Erst mal lexie dafür genommen und dann
Das was abkackt ist ja der crawler teil den ich nicht programmiert habe
meins kackt natürlich nicht ab
Habt ihr schon jemals was was ich programmiert habe crashen gesehen
Das kann eigentlich also doch kann eigentlich nicht sein
Aber was war das hier jetzt what the fuck welcome to flatter
Flatter tool google analytics
Google analytics ernsthaft die haben google analytics in ihr scheiß kommando zeilen tool eingebaut dafür
Die was aber gleich wissen
Ok was hat der jetzt android tool chain ist not available chrome develop for web nicht available
Kein android studio das macht er nicht ich will ja auch mal eine desktop app ausprobieren. Oh ob flatter was hier los
Ok flatter was install und ob flatter if you intend to use it as regular user
At your user into the group flatter users
Ist es vielleicht besser man ins den flatter von hand anstatt über den paket manager
Ok wie installiert man ok flatter install wie macht man das offiziell
install install linux ok vielleicht vielleicht ist das sogar bisschen voller jit muss installiert sein
Snap on ks also bevor ich das mit snap installier dann dann installiere ich das lieber über den package manager
Ne
Manually manually klingt gut manual exzellent if you don't want fixed version
Ok leute wir installieren es jetzt mal von hand ich habe irgendwie so die doofe vermutung das wird nicht richtig funktionieren hier über den package manager
Wenn er das in so komischen ordnern hat und man jetzt erst mal user hinzufügen muss und sowas
Ich ich entferne das noch mal schnell
Wir können es wir können es immer noch
Aber flatter ist schon fein ja kann sie immer noch installieren
Mk dir flatter flutter also ich werde es definitiv nicht über snap machen auf snap habe ich nämlich gar keinen bock
Einfach snap schottladen ja ok also
If you don't want fixed version get source code from flatter repo exzellent flatter repo clone
Mk immer gespannt ob man damit linux desktop apps machen kann und ob die mittlerweile den web view haben
Schauen wir mal so
jit clone
Brauchen wir nicht
Git sollte ja standardmäßig master haben auf auf lauter
Aber jetzt ist es ja nicht so
Aber heute schauen wir mal flip 동
tool to your path
wie das liegt einfach da rum oder was?
das liegt jetzt einfach da rum?
ja shell kriegt ich ein bin
tatsächlich
das liegt einfach da rum
das flutter tool
bam
wie das wars schon?
ja das brauchen wir nicht
run flutter doktor
ok
exellent
oh jetzt
ach das war vorher nur
nur die hälfte oder so
jetzt kommt es eigentlich install
tja
hausgemachte probleme
man hätte es so einfach haben können
es einfach so lassen und es würde alles
funktionieren aber nein
man muss ja an dingen rum
doktornika in sin machen
achso das hatten wir
gerade schon alles in ordnung
das passt
aber du kannst das
garantiert umstellen aber trotzdem
ok das ist missing
ok das ist missing ist es nicht schlimm
so desktop
flutter support
snap
ich will kein snap
setup
ok flutter
config enable linux desktop
alles klar
bam
wie das wars und nun wie gehts jetzt
wieder
ja ja gut ich hab
nix zum restarten
ok sicherstellen dass der desktop enabled
ist das erinnert mich voll an android irgendwie
ich weiß nicht warum das snap weil ich snap
nicht mag
flutter connected devices
exellent
ok linux desktop
snap sacked ja find ich auch
das haben wir doch gerade schon gemacht
der doktor
haben wir laufen lassen
oh geht nicht
aha
ok
ich muss zeug installieren also
was muss ich für kram installieren
übrigens ich dachte früher
immer das heißt
aber heißt gar nicht
ich hab jetzt schon einige
konferenztalks und so gesehen
die haben das als klang ausgesprochen
klang
aber das haben wir doch alles drauf
cmake hab ich doch
eh wir haben eindeutig zu wenig
c++ stels gemacht hier drauf
ninja
gleich kommt noch fortnite
wird auch noch installiert
wie heißt denn das ding hier
ah das ist installiert ok
pkg
config
da alles brauche
ist installiert
und gtk
ok
das ist auch installiert
ok nice
also können wir weitermachen was sagt der doktor jetzt
der doktor sagt
bam
funktioniert
exellent
ok weiter gehts
was ist denn
leute ich hab jetzt ja gehört
dass ihr im chat schon ein paar leute mit
erfahrung und flatter was ist die beste flatter ide
hat
hat atlasian schon
nicht einfach sag ich atlasian
jetbrains schon irgendwas
hier ist
code gibt es eine offizielle
flutter extension für
flutter extension
eh
test
nee test ist schlecht
das ist so zu nennen
kek weight heißt unser erstes projekt
beste
flutter
flutter alter flutter und
dart extension
jetbrains gibt es da was
muss ich mal kurz gucken
ach nee plugins
flu
was denn das
für ne paints champ bezeichnung
wahrscheinlich weil google nicht wollte dass
das flatter genannt wird
ok
das haben wir gemacht
aber gemacht hat alles funktioniert
create and run
flutter create my app
ok das mag ich schon mal das
sieht relativ easy aus
create my app
ok ich mach
jetzt eins zu eins mal so wie es in dem
in der anleitung drin steht man weiß
ja nie
ok
nice cd my app da wäre ich jetzt
auch so drauf gekommen
da ist jetzt das ganze zeug drin
aha
to launch your application from command line
ok jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
ob das funktioniert
der flutter champ
iiih
heißt das das basiert auf gtk unter linux
oder benutzen die da bloß
irgendwelche base dinge drauf ich dachte flutter
rendert komplett selbst
alle controls
warum brauchen die gtk
was soll denn das
oh da ist es guck mal
ok es sieht original aus wie eine android app
die aber relativ
gut läuft
text rendering ist
so jetzt was ich mich jetzt interessieren
wird ist da gtk drunter
was willst du für ein app programmieren
gar keine ich will mir das einfach mal angucken
ist da gtk drunter oder benutzen
die das nur um fenster zu erstellen oder so was
also sprich
ist das hier eigentlich ein gtk button
oder
ist das wirklich
flutter button den flutter da
malt mit frag mich nicht ob ein gl oder so
also
ist flutter unter linux nur
gtk wrapper ich hoffe mal nicht
ok wir können den button pushen und es funktioniert
ich bin begeistert
keyboard shortcuts funktionieren alle nicht
debug
egal ein nicer
button wird gepusht
ich weiß nicht so sieht jetzt halt nicht unbedingt
eine normale linux app aus aber
sieht halt aus wie eine mobile app
aber das ist ja schon irgendwo klar
ist ja auch das default template
ok excellent gehen wir mal hier raus
zack
ist das ein chrome
also
hot reload
also ich hab ja ich hab mich damit nicht weiter beschäftigt
ich dachte das flutter was komplett eigenes ist also das ist kein chrome
und im endeffekt auch kein
kein electron light
oder so und es ist auch kein
wrapper für schon bestehende
ui sachen
sondern so wie ich das verstanden hab
rendert flutter wirklich alles selbst
also sprich das ist kein gtk button
nur ein bisschen anders gestylt
sondern das ist ein richtig echter flutter button
den wir da grad hatten
in irgendwie was auch immer
in ein open gl fenster oder so reingerendert
so
ok dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal
yo der chat ist
confident
hier so
oder gibt mir recht yep
so zeig es mal her
jetzt brauchen wir erstmal die flutter extension
ios test web
linux hier
flutter
alter wieviel 30
milliarden sachen
wo ist mein sourcecode
gibt's net overrated
prominent
warum kein android studio
ist das besser
ich hab keine ahnung
met 3f
sieben monat danke für den sub
wo ist mein sourcecode
ich mein ich würde ja
main dart
ah yes
ok search
also leute die 2
dinger oder wie oder was oder wo
dart flutter
reiner zufall
dankeschön prime gaming
huge sub
ah verstehe
cute mod 2.0 ist am start
so
also install
install
war mein aim zu schlecht gerade
der scam train ist am start nice
94% leute
1 sub brauchen wir noch
dann haben wir es geschafft lasst euch mal
scammen
ja
11 monat dankeschön
das ist ja 1 vor hyper subscription
ok ich glaube euch
einfach dass das passt
nice wir haben es geschafft massive
datains hat abos verschenkt schon insgesamt
wer hat was gekriegt der altes
hatten stufe 1 abo gekriegt nice tensor
kampf kevin auch am start
joho 27
jetzt gehts aber ab hier leute
12 subs jetzt sind wir schon auf stufe 3
habt ihr euch nice jubeln lassen von twitch
exellent
IQ++ ja bald
also bald reicht für den chat echt nicht mal
5 hat da müssen wir den kopf schon ein bisschen
erweitern in die richtung
so
ok
alles jetzt alles
geinstalled wunderbar
hoff wir haben syntax
highlighting leute ich fass es net
haben wir auch my home page
ok ich muss jetzt erstmal kurz
kurz verarbeiten was ich hier sehe
ich hab noch nie was mit dat
gemacht und ich hab noch nie was mit flutter
gemacht also
import erstmal gucken haben wir
irgendwie autocomplete
für die imports
package
ja wir haben autocomplete
für die imports ok alles klar
also
lass mal kurz kurz
checken was was ich hier sehe
also
class my app
my app extends
main ok da kann ich mir was drunter vorstellen
dass das ok also
so macht man anscheinend functions
also void
int
haben wir sowas aha lull
das sieht ja relativ
standardmäßig aus
oh das allerwichtigste ich muss checken
ob das die
go syntax ist für fl
nein nein bitte nicht
nicht die go syntax für fl
hört mal auf google
geh weg geh weg
das ist so painz
champion alter wer macht denn
sowas
wer macht so sein fl
wer macht denn sowas
console
right
ach nee hör mal auf
komm
echt gibt's wirklich jemand der die go syntax
mag kann ich mir grad vorstellen
muss man eigentlich semi colon machen oder so
das ist doch die gute fl syntax
was
nee
im leben net
die beste fl
syntax ist
entweder meinetwegen sowas
aber ich persönlich bin ja für sowas
warum nicht so es sieht doch viel besser aus
viel klarer was da los ist
ja
iiii guckt euch das mal an
das richtiger painz champ
hox vier monat dankeschön
für den sub
heute müsst ihr besonders dringend
ad wupplos davor schreiben wenn ich was sehen soll
weil ich glaub das
ich muss jetzt konzentrieren
so also was seh ich dir noch
ok ich hab wie gesagt ich hab auch von daten keinen plan
also ich seh hier main
so das ist wahrscheinlich
oh komm mal man kann direkt runnen
ok das find ich cool
und jetzt
startet es jetzt
oh
da ist es
nice
max max ist konfidiert
ja gut es ist ey
aber das ist ja
ja
ja gut es ist ey
aber das ist die standard app wenn die nicht konfidiert
wir machen jetzt
ein bmi rechner
das ist die beste
standard wir machen ein bmi rechner
haha
ehm
dat devtools
includes additional
tools for debugging and profiling
include a widget
was
what
open
jetzt ist es weg
was was war
widget
widget inspektor
was inspektiert der
ah hier guck mal
ok da funktioniert nicht so ganz der widget inspektor
würde ich sagen
oh nice ich
darf die app nicht beenden mit dem normalen
shortcut oh die app ist gecrashed
ich glaube wir haben es kaputt gemacht
monarch s
kaputt
ok beenden
jawoll terminator mach kaputt
wie moment
warum ist es noch da
das soll
das soll weg
oh jetzt habe ich es verschoben
auf den anderen desktop jetzt ist es
verschwunden
ist es jetzt noch da
oder ist es weg
ok
ich runne nochmal
das ist bestimmt noch gestartet
jetzt irgendwie transparent oder so
ah ne ok passt
kann man das jetzt normal beenden
ok ok
also passt also was sehe ich denn jetzt hier
das ist so ein zwischending
zwischen java und
attributes und ruby
so eine swift java
mischung oder so
ein bisschen
ja
kobol
genau erinnert mich auf den ersten
blick an kobol ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht
this is the theme of
your application primary
ok was kann man nochmal blue
da kann man jetzt sagen
black
und dann kann man
starten
oh ne das hat es kaputt gemacht oder
warum hat es das kaputt gemacht
blue ist ok
aber black ist broken
warum
hä
run
oh es ist gecrashed
leute
es ist gecrashed
oder? ne doch nicht sah nur so aus
ok
warum geht blue
hä
warum geht blue und black geht nicht
ah moment black ist eine color
und blue ist eine
material color
ok das finde ich ja schonmal
äußerst verwirrend
ok black gibt es nicht als material color
alles klar
ok ich hab
keine ahnung warum aber
warum gibt es da 30 verschiedene colors
und alles
im gleichen color objekt
ok deep purple
starten
so das heißt unser button unten
müsste jetzt lila sein
ha
der chat täuscht wieder vor trigger zu sein
ach guck mal das ganze theme
ist jetzt
lila
unser lehrer
in der schule bei dem wir das
fach IT systeme hatten
ihr könnt euch vorstellen so geil war das nicht
wir haben im prinzip nur ein bisschen
mit microsoft office rum gewurstet
und du hast mal immer eine eins gekriegt
wenn du lila reingemacht hast
in das dokument
dann hat er sich gefreut und ist rumgerannt
leila leila leila und hat eine eins gegeben
weiß nicht was
mit dem kerl los war der auf jeden fall nicht mehr ganz
dicht und wir haben dort eines der
schlimmsten sachen überhaupt gemacht
microsoft
access
ne quatsch aber wobei
wahrscheinlich 97
ich glaube wir haben wirklich microsoft access
access 97 gemacht
das kommt ungefähr hin
das hier
ja
du große
scheiße
keck wait
Payness
gab's access 95
das war schon painststr銅 Mind
alter
das war schon richtig painststr
warum hat man eigentlich überhaupt
access verwendet
Reiner Zufall, schon hast du am start bis umgleich gesubbt. So mag ich das, so muss das sein.
Das ist Doppel IQ Steigerung für den Chat.
Okay, okay, also ich wollte jetzt ja eigentlich gucken, was ich hier sehe.
Also ich sehe irgendeinen Main Widget, also das ist wahrscheinlich mein Root Element vermute ich mal.
My App. Das ist im Prinzip sowas wie Body bei HTML.
So und hier sind so die Default, die Default Styling für die gesamte App.
So und dann gibt es den Start von meiner App ist dann quasi My Homepage.
So und was sehe ich jetzt hier? My Homepage erbt von Stateful Widget.
Also ich rate jetzt im Prinzip nur, weil ich hab von Dart und Flutter keine Ahnung.
So, das hier sieht mir ein bisschen aus wie Constructor Chaining.
Also sprich, also wenn, was ist denn das da hinten dran?
Was ist das? Das verstehe ich.
Also im Prinzip das hier ruft den Constructor davon auf, das verstehe ich.
Aber was macht denn hier dieses?
Ist das der normale Constructor, den man hier nur inline schreibt oder was?
Oder? Nee.
Ach, das sind die Parameter, oder? Kann das sein was für Parameter man braucht, dass man das instanzieren kann?
Aha, okay, verstehe. Also ich sehe ich muss mal ein Dart Tutorial machen, glaube ich.
This is Homepage of your App, it is Stateful, meaning...
State Object, Final, String, Title, okay, kann ich da mehrere Sachen machen?
String, Keg, W, Lul, geht das?
Nee, das geht nicht, weil das übergebe ich hier oben nicht.
Was ist, was macht denn Key an der Stelle?
Aber ich kann jetzt sagen, Required, This, Lul.
Und dann?
Ach so, Moment, das geht ja nicht, das ist ja Custom Class, okay.
Alles klar, nice.
Ach, jetzt kann man das natürlich nicht instanzieren, weil das hier aufgerufen wird, aber ich kann hier wahrscheinlich das übergeben.
Okay, Lul kriegt jetzt Empty String.
So, das scheint zu funktionieren.
Mal gucken, ob das auch startet jetzt.
Das Starten dauert aber schon nervig lang, ne?
So, jetzt können wir den geilen Button pushen.
Wie kriegt man das eigentlich ohne Debug gestartet?
Wir haben es doch vorhin gestartet mit Minus D, ne?
Kann man das einfach ohne Minus D starten, dann ist es ohne Debug?
Ah, nee.
Vielleicht eher Release?
Help.
Wow, 30 Milliarden Dinger.
D ist die Weiß-, nee.
Dann musst du ein Bild machen, okay, Flutter, Bild.
Flutter, Bild, Linux.
Okay, also ich muss sagen, das Kommando Zeilen Tool gefällt mir.
Ah, ich muss nicht neu starten, das reloadet.
Ah, das ist cool.
Das ist nice, das probieren wir gleich mal aus.
So, und wo liegt das Bild jetzt?
Wahrscheinlich irgendwo hier oben drüber in Builds?
Nee.
Ach so, ich bin wieder rausgegangen.
In Builds.
Linux.
x86 Release.
What the fuck, und wie starte ich das jetzt?
Flutter, but what?
Wofür benutzt man Flutter, um grafische Anwendung zu machen?
Wie startet man den Kram jetzt, Bundle?
My App, aha.
My App.
Oh, das geht jetzt ja relativ zackig.
Das geht relativ zügig jetzt.
Fühlt sich auch gleich deutlich geschwindter an.
Ja.
Für welche Sprache?
Dart, das ist eine eigene Sprache.
Wieso zeigt dein LS so viele Infos an?
Weil das kein LS ist, sondern das ist eigentlich EXA.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das noch weiterentwickelt wird.
Das ist ein LS in Rust nachgebaut.
Okay, wird anscheinend noch weiterentwickelt.
Ist relativ beliebt, sogar auf GitHub.
Okay, das heißt, wir haben jetzt live Reload.
Moment, jetzt müssen wir einfach gucken, wie groß ist denn so eine Flutter App?
Was braucht man überhaupt, um die Flutter App laufen zu lassen?
Das komplette Verzeichnis oder nur die App?
Ah nee, das komplette Verzeichnis wahrscheinlich.
Warum brauchen die GTK?
Also sprich, wenn ich die App jetzt beispielsweise...
My App, wenn ich die jetzt eins hochkopiere, dann geht es nicht mehr.
Ja, genau.
Kann man Flutter Self-Contained Build? Geht das?
Flutter?
Ich habe noch nicht verstanden, für was die jetzt genau...
Okay, anscheinend gibt es kein Self-Contained Build.
App-Images, ja gut.
Cool, wenn es das komplett vorauskönnte.
Google steht da ja drauf, machen sie mit Go auch.
Aber was die jetzt genau GTK verwenden, habe ich nicht verstanden.
Wahrscheinlich, um so Sachen zu machen, wie Fenster erstellen und Mausklicks mitbekommen und sowas.
So, wie groß ist denn der Kram?
Was ist das, Bundle?
550 MB, das geht. Das ist in der heutigen Zeit durchaus in Ordnung.
Wie viel RAM braucht so eine Flutter-App?
Ich überlege gerade.
Wie ist das nochmal?
Mit S-Mem konnte man gucken und mit...
Egal, ich nehme irgendeinen GUI Prozess Explorer oder so.
Ja, mit Hardtop ist immer so eine Sache, wenn das Ding mehrere Threads hat.
Es gibt so eine S-Mem-Abwandlung, die ist gar nicht so übel.
Guck, weil hier siehst du nicht, was das alles...
My App, 128 MB.
Web-Content.
Ja, ich meine...
128 MB, das geht, wenn es nicht wirklich viel größer wird.
128 MB für eine Hello World App ist natürlich relativ viel.
Aber ich meine, da ist ja auch schon einiges geladen zum Rendern.
Die Frage ist, wie schnell das größer wird, wenn man da Sachen hinzufügt.
Nee, also ich finde, 128 MB ist schon in Ordnung.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit, wenn du mal guckst, was so Elektronenscheiß braucht, wenn es gestartet ist.
Okay, also jetzt müssen wir die Live-Reload-Geschichte ausprobieren.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Also wir können das starten und dann können wir die Farbe ändern und das ändert live die Farbe, oder wie?
Jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Okay, machen wir Blue.
Ha, boah, das ist ja nice.
Man muss das nicht neu starten und er erkennt sofort die neuen Settings.
Ja, das ist cool.
Pock.
Richtig Pock.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, sehr schön.
Okay, was sehe ich sonst noch so?
Constructor, irgendwelche Class Variablen oder so.
Override, das checke ich nicht so genau.
Das ist sowas wie...
Gut, das ist wahrscheinlich eine Methode aus StatefulWidget überschrieben.
Woher weiß ich denn, was ich alles overrideen kann?
Okay, anscheinend. Nee, Moment.
MyHomePageState kann doch davon nichts sein.
Woher weiß es, dass es MyHomePageState gibt?
Wo kommt denn MyHomePageState?
Ach, da unten drunter ist MyHomePageState.
Ach so.
Aber warum was overrideet er denn da?
Okay, das habe ich noch nicht so genau gecheckt, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ich finde das mit Dart bis jetzt gar nicht so schlimm.
Ich habe halt keine Ahnung davon.
What the fuck?
Ach, das ist jetzt das eigentliche Layout oder was?
Moment, warum gibt es MyHomePage?
Und dann gibt es MyHomePageState?
Und im State ist das Layout?
Warum ist das Layout im State?
Okay.
Also, wenn ich da jetzt reinschreibe...
Qt...
Chat...
Aja, ja.
Dann steht...
Aber das, also ich muss sagen, das live reloaden ist schon cool.
Das ist nice, das gefällt mir.
Macht er das hier automatisch?
Ah, das fügt er hier automatisch rein.
Das finde ich cool.
Sowas könnten die beide Way in HTML auch machen.
Zwischendrin, dass man sieht, was was ist und an welcher Ebene.
Floating Action Button, das ist das Ding da unten.
Ach, hier Tooltip.
So, was hat das Ding noch?
Elevation.
Dann, wie hervorgehoben der ist oder was?
Zehn?
Ich sehe da keinen Unterschied vom Action Button.
Hier, was auch immer.
Focus Color?
Okay, jetzt aktuell Focus Color nix.
Focus Color...
Color?
Oh.
Nee, was war das?
Colors, ne?
Focus Color ist gelb.
Vielleicht gehe ich da drüber?
Oder auch nicht?
Hm.
Hover?
Ah, Hover Color.
Colors.
Jetzt aber.
Ah.
Auch wenn man das jetzt noch animieren könnte, wäre schon cooler.
Okay, jetzt haben wir Huge Color geändert.
Allerwichtigste aller Zeiten.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich kann man Animationen sich so einfach machen.
Child Icon.
Okay, da kann man verschiedene Sachen angeben, was man haben will.
Wahrscheinlich...
Ah, das sind so die Standard Material Design Icons, die man hier hat.
Gibt es eigentlich für Flutter auch noch was anderes als Material Design?
Also, könnte man eine Flutter Anwendung aussehen lassen wie Windows?
Oder ist das alles Material Design?
Weil irgendwo schreiben die doch hier, Returns Material App.
Kann man sagen, Returns Material App.
Was gibt es sonst noch für Apps?
App.
Cupertino App.
Das sieht dann aus wie Apple, oder wie?
Okay.
Lul.
Okay, dann musst du mal rumgucken.
Flutter.
Okay, das ist Big Brain.
Der neue Ubuntu Installer wird in Flutter geschrieben, okay.
Aber auch nicht.
Okay, das funktioniert schon mal nicht, wie ich mir das so gedacht habe.
Wir bleiben beim Standard Design, glaube ich.
Oh, wenn es gecrashed ist, ist gecrashed, dann reloadet es sich nicht mehr automatisch.
Okay, wenn man es schafft, dass die App crashed, muss man neu starten.
Interessant.
Das ist ja auch gut, kann ich verstehen.
Was?
Kann ich mal starten, please?
Okay, also was gibt es denn eigentlich?
Material App.
Da wollten sie nicht Apple schreiben.
Was gibt es denn da noch alles?
Gibt es auch Windows App?
Nee, es gibt bloß die zwei, oder?
Ah, es gibt anscheinend nur die zwei.
Okay.
Na ja.
Dann bleiben wir erstmal bei Material Design.
Ich meine, man kann ja auch mit Material Design die Sachen nicht ganz so Android-mäßig aussehen lassen.
Okay, also was haben wir jetzt sonst noch?
Was ich jetzt mal gucken will, ist, kann man...
Wie füge ich jetzt hier was Neues ein?
Also, Widget, Texts, Counter, Floating Action Button.
So, der Button ist hier.
Kann ich jetzt anstatt dem Button hier nochmal...
Sag mal, ich mache da jetzt noch einen Button rein.
Geht das?
Nope.
Okay.
Wie kriege ich da noch einen Button rein?
Column.
Ah, das hier ist die Column und das ist quasi eine Variable.
Das heißt, ich kann das nicht zweimal machen.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich will jetzt einfach nur ein bisschen rumspielen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich jetzt irgendwie super...
Also, wie mache ich denn Textfeld?
Okay, Flutter, Textfeld.
Textfield.
Bam.
Ach, so einfach kann es gehen?
Sollte ich vielleicht einfach mal die Default App wegwerfen?
Was?
Excusi ist gebannt?
Echt?
Warum?
Pardon.
Oh.
Warum ist das schon wieder gebannt?
Ach, der wurde auf GTA gebannt.
Was hat er denn wieder gemacht?
Okay, das heißt, wir schmeißen jetzt mal die Default App weg.
Moment.
Das geht ja noch weiter da unten.
Okay, das ist Big Brain.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da abgeht.
Was soll...
Okay, so wahnsinnig intuitiv ist es jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was ich machen muss.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt was Schlechtes.
Ach, hier.
Children.
Hier kann man Sachen reinschreiben, denke ich mal, ne?
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt hier noch mal Text.
Okay.
Also hier kann ich jetzt noch was reinmachen.
Hier kann ich jetzt auch mal ein Textfeld reinmachen.
Ah, bam, mein Textfeld ist am Start.
Huge Textfeld.
Hacker man.
Äh, Obscure Text, false.
Ah, yes.
Excellent, excellent.
Dude, aber es ist ganz schön laggy.
Es ist ganz schön laggy, wenn du hier reinklickst.
Also gut funktionieren ist, tut es nett.
Klick, klick.
Und jetzt habe ich, ich habe jetzt schon fünfmal rausgeklickt und es geht nicht weg.
Sollte nicht, sollte nicht der Text endselected werden, wenn ich rausklicke?
Oder muss man das selbst machen?
Das liegt an Debug.
Und wenn ich hier reinklicke, wird es auch nicht selected, nur hier.
Ach, guck mal, wenn ich auf den Button klick, nee, auf Button geht es.
Nice Passwort Leak, ja.
Okay, das heißt, ich soll ein Build machen und das dann besser.
Okay, Build, Linux, auf, Bilder.
Was würdest du für Android Apps empfehlen, wenn man keine Webseite hat zum In-App konvertieren?
Ich kann es dir nicht sagen, ich habe noch nie eine Android App gemacht.
Also ich, ganz ehrlich, also mal angenommen, ich möchte jetzt eine Android App machen,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch eine iOS App machen wollen und ich würde wahrscheinlich
gucken, dass ich irgendeine Ionic Webseite bastle oder den Hentai Viewer, nee, aber dann
ich würde wahrscheinlich gucken, dass ich irgendeine Ionic Webseite bastle, Vue.js Webseite
und dann konvertieren zu irgendwas Native mäßiges.
Ich habe keine Ahnung davon, ich habe das noch nie gemacht.
Okay, also Build, Linux, Release, Moment, da war es doch schon, My App, oh, oh, das ist
die alte, die hätte ich mal löschen müssen, Blatter, nee, Bundle muss ich, Bundle, Bundle
My App.
Also man muss sagen, das ist aber nice, dass das relativ schnell startet, das finde ich
schon mal gut.
Okay, es ist nicht mehr so laggy, aber das mit dem Fokus funktioniert immer nicht, aber
das liegt wahrscheinlich an mir, okay, also es ist auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht so laggy
wie vorher.
Ah doch, oh doch, das ist ganz schön laggy, alter, es ist laggy, boah, das verschluckt
Tastenanschläge, okay, das ist noch nicht so gut, so, kommt mal weiter, gibt es den Webview,
allerwichtigste an, die wichtigen Sachen müssen wir mal abchecken, Flutter, Linux, Webview,
Blatter, Webview, aha, auf dem Desktop schon mal nett, wie, da ist kein eingebauter Webview,
echt nicht, kann ich einfach sagen, Web, Web, Widget oder so, Webview, nee, gibt es nicht.
Ist das vielleicht wegen Emulationen, ja, es ist die Frage, wie die das malen, also ich
bin mir immer noch nicht so ganz sicher, wie die Architektur ist, ich meine, die brauchen
zwar GTK, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das wirklich nur ein GTK Reskin ist.
Ich vermute mal, dass die GTK verwenden für so Sachen wie, wie gesagt, Fenster öffnen,
schließen, Mausevents handeln und sonst was, ich denke mal, dass die, dass die eigentliche
App auch kein, auch kein Chrome ist, sondern dass das wirklich ein, ja, was auch immer
für eine darunter liegende Rendergeschichte ist, OpenGL, Vulkan, ich habe keine Ahnung,
was da unten drunter ist, Xserver Software Rendering, keine Ahnung, und dann malen die
einfach ihre Sachen ins Fenster rein, also einfach in Anführungsstrichen, ok, den Webview
für Flutter Desktop gibt es anscheinend nicht, das ist schon mal doof, Skia, ja, das kann
auch sein, ja, aber das ist die Frage, was benutzt die, weil irgendwie muss die ja auf
die Grafik hatte, das Zeug, Jailor nebenbei, Boopcam schauen vermute ich jetzt mal, weiß
ich nicht, kann man das aufmachen, ist das safe, ich will wissen, was der Jailor sich
da anguckt, what the fuck, lul, was ist hier los, sind wir auf, wie heißt das, nicht Pornhub,
wie heißt das Ding noch mal für die Webcams, ah, keine Ahnung, lul, Alter, Chatrobate,
genau, lul, was geht hier eigentlich ab auf Twitch mittlerweile, oh man, soll ich das
auch mal machen, Chat, soll ich das auch machen, soll ich auch mal die Hose halt runterziehen,
soll ich filmen dabei, genau, wette ich, ey, Leute, ohne Scheiß, wetten, wetten, ich würde
gebannt werden, ich würde gebannt werden, entspannt Arsch in die Kamera, Alter, OnlyFans
man, oh man, Leute, ich fürchte, dass mit Flutter wirklich nicht so wirklich was, weil
ich müsste erstmal ein bisschen Dart lernen, ich tue mir unglaublich schwer hier durch
zu blicken, was hier gerade eigentlich abgeht, ein Webview gibt es anscheinend auch nicht,
ok, Jailor kennt sich aus, aber wir müssen jetzt hier nicht übertreiben, man kann ja
auf die jeweiligen Channels gehen, wenn man das gerne sieht, Leute, ich weiß nicht, was
ich machen soll, ich hab mir das jetzt ein bisschen easier vorgestellt, ich dachte mir,
es sieht aus wie vielleicht, wie normale UI Frameworks von der Programmiersprache, die
man halt irgendwie versteht, ich hab legit absolut keinen Schimmer, was hier sich tut
gerade, ich muss mir mal ein Dart Tutorial Offstream angucken, das wird sonst nix, so
wie, ups, SVGA Surface Destroy, löscht mal die Kommentare, dann sieht es weniger plaud
aus, das ist wohl wahr, aber dann hab ich ja noch weniger Ahnung, was hier passiert,
es sieht auch nicht schlecht aus, also es ist auf jeden Fall nichts, was mich jetzt irgendwie
an ekliche Ausflüchse von C++ erinnert oder so, das sieht eigentlich relativ clean aus
und man kann das auch gut lesen, das Problem ist, ich hab kein plassen Schimmer, wie was
zusammenhängt, das ist mein Hauptsichtlesproblem, ah, ohne Trailing, sucked, ah, verstehe,
Flutter Tutorial von NetNinja, den hab ich schon öfters mal geguckt, das ist auf jeden
Fall nice, also eine Sache, die ich wirklich gut finde, wo sich noch mehr UI Frameworks
was von abschneiden könnten, die halt nicht komplett browser-based sind, da geht es ja
zum größten Teil schon, ist die Live-Reload-Geschichte, also das ist auf jeden Fall eine coole Sache,
ne, also wenn man das hier offen hat und sagt jetzt hier, keine Ahnung, man möchte die
ganze Application auf einmal in yellow haben und speichert und das ganze Ding wird yellow,
das ist auf jeden Fall äußerst nice, wie würde ich denn jetzt hier in das Passwortfeld
überhaupt was reinschreiben, äh, Skiaflutter benutzt OpenGL, OpenGL ES, Vulkan und mehr,
ok, das ergibt Sinn und PDF, was zum Teufel ist PDF, also das hat bestimmt nichts mit
PDF zu tun, was ich mir unter PDF vorstelle, ok, also ich vermute mal, wenn ich hier was
reinschreiben will, dann bräuchte ich so eine Art Data-Binding, ne, wie kriege ich in das
Textfeld den Text rein und raus, reading values, what, onpress, you typed values, ok, ok, ok,
you typed value, content, ne, Moment, child textfield, wow, das ist echt next level shit,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was das treibt, Textfield, Controller, unsubmitted, ok, unsubmitted
macht man inline irgendwie ein Text oder so, also sprich unsubmitted und dann hier irgendwie
hook,ез, alerts, alert-dialog, ne, un-returned die Dinge dann, boa, das ist übelst另外lich,
das ist übelst undurchsichtig.
Kann es dann jemand im Terminal ausgeben?
console
Du kannst das in der variablen speichern sprich also
Wo ist mein counter wo ist mein counter counter dollar counter
Kontext
Wo ist die variablen für den für den counter
counter
Moment wo kommt das her
Ach das kommt aus dem my home page state das haben wir da oben aha ok
Also
Könnte ich jetzt quasi wenn ich in das text viel was eingebe wir machen jetzt mal nicht den counter wir machen jetzt mal was eigenes irgendwie
string
loop
so was
Und dann
Kann ich hier im moment wo ist denn hier überhaupt was gewesen jetzt hier uns abmitted
Kann ich jetzt sagen das das mag ich übrigens schon mal ich ich ich finde es ja immer ach so näher
Muss man eigentlich am ende semi kohle und machen oder nicht ja muss man
Set state nicht vergessen was zum
So
Ich habe kein absolut keine ahnung ok kann ich jetzt an der stelle sagen ich will
Ich will meine plupp variablen haben geht das
So einfach schau mal nicht
Increment counter
ja
Ach so
Ach
Ah, verstehe, verstehe.
Okay, also die stehen auf diese Geschichte mit Underscore für private Sachen, finde
ich eigentlich okay.
Bin ich eigentlich auch so gewohnt, okay.
Okay, jetzt, aha, so, und jetzt kann ich hier unten sagen, blub, ha, nee, aah, okay,
ich muss Enter drücken, keck, wait, ach man muss Underscore machen oder wie, okay, es,
okay, wenn es unsubmitted gibt, gibt es auch bestimmt mal on, unchanged, unchanged, das
ist auch nice, jetzt kriege ich es beim tippen, guckt, bam, poggers, p, o, g, r, s, excellent,
so mag ich das, okay, einfach rausgehen, es ist schon relativ laggy, muss man sagen, das
könnte aber auch an der vm liegen, aber so eine einfache Sache muss in der vm auch schon
gut funktionieren, wie soll es sonst was komplexeres funktionieren.
Okay, hast du schon mal in proxmox gearbeitet, wir haben es hier schon ausprobiert, ja, es
ist ganz nett, aber ich werde es nicht einsetzen, ich habe da lieber kein GUI dazwischen, ich
mag meinen laggischen ubuntu server, paar containers drauf und eine vm, fertig, die vm ist super
um das layout zu testen, meinst du jetzt meine vm wäre vm oder die flutter vm, sir old crowd,
alles schon für den sub, zwei monate, excellent subscription, aber ich habe, ich habe ein
bild gemacht, ich habe ein bild gemacht, das war jetzt auch nicht so super snappy, ja aber
schon auf jeden fall besser als das hier, okay nice, das erinnert mich ein bisschen an java
script zeug, gibt es eigentlich sonst noch irgendwas, was dart verwendet, außer eben,
ist das so die hauseigene, warum haben die eigentlich für flutter dart verwendet, jetzt
mal ganz im ernst, weil das bedeutet doch im endeffekt auch, du kannst keinerlei schon
existierende libraries verwenden, kannst du versuchen links und rechts, das ist eine gute
idee, müssen wir mal gucken, wie das geht, border, textfield oder margin, nein, wir googeln
einfach, flutter, textfield, margin, padding, jetzt bei das nicht, so spacing, add padding,
was alt enter, what the fuck, ach android studio, achja also, child text, style, ah
da kann man doch einen style dazu angeben hier, style, ne hier, style, style, ne, da vielleicht,
ah style, okay ist größer, habt ihr gesehen, das ist größer geworden, das hat prinzipiell
funktioniert, margin, padding, ne, okay was, ah moment, das ist ja nur textstyle, das ist
ja nur textstyle, ich will ja kein textstyle, ich brauch irgendwie, okay wie geht das jetzt,
background, background color, spacing, hab ich da was von spacing gesehen, okay das ist
nur für text, das brauchen wir nicht, padding, what, padding, wrap das textfield, okay das
heißt, padding, okay also padding, 30, und jetzt sag ich child wahrscheinlich, ne, child
und child kommt dann das textfield rein, okay was, was gibt's bei padding dann, gibt's
hier, wow, ah oben unten links rechts, ah guck mal hier, das ist doch relativ gut durchdacht
muss ich sagen, all, all 20, hey das ist, ja das ist doch eigentlich ganz nett, was wird
denn geprockt, gar nichts ich guck's mir einfach nur an, ich guck mir das einfach nur ein
bisschen an, ich hab damit noch nie was gemacht, okay aber die performance, kann ich das jetzt
eigentlich bilden von linux aus für windows, wait a minute, enable, enable, windows, das
geht wahrscheinlich nicht oder, wine, ey wenn das in wine läuft, okay build, windows, ah
build windows only supported on windows hosts, okay das ist verständlich, auf windows will
ich's mir jetzt nicht noch gerade nicht installieren, okay also, so wie krieg ich das jetzt oben
aligned, das ist das nächste, das ist ja alles in der mitte, also child column, da brauch
ich jetzt wahrscheinlich, ah body center, guck mal, gibt's da so viel top, center, top ist
standard, einfach nur top, nee oder, also ich kann theoretisch das center dann einfach
weg, das child einfach weg machen, nee, guck mal der löscht das manchmal, guck mal der
erkennt meine backspace-taste nicht, lulw, was ist das, der erkennt mein backspace nicht,
okay das ist, okay der erkennt weder file-tasten, vorwärts und rückwärts erkennt er, aber
hä, okay das ist verbackt, boogie, jetzt geht's, lul, so das heißt jetzt auch nicht password
sondern cacw-input, input-decoration, aber das ist trotzdem, also das finde ich ist eine
coole Sache, wie sie das hier gelöst haben mit dem bestyling, so wie align ich das denn
jetzt oben, ach hier, top, center-end, also start, warum genau war das jetzt center-aligned,
so das ist bisschen flexbox lite jetzt quasi, demo-homepage, cute-chat-app, so wir brauchen
ein image, wir brauchen ein image, wir brauchen unbedingt ein image, wie macht man ein image,
platter-image, wir brauchen ayayaya-image, what, what, hier, image, was ist das, so das
ist, also sprich wir machen jetzt hier oben, hier unten drunter, unter dem textfeld, hier
ist das textfeld zu ende, machen wir ein image, nee, moment, hier, ah yes, unable to load
asset, ja klar, haben wir ja auch nicht, so wo macht man die assets jetzt hin, build,
platter-assets, ah per datei, ich kann aber einfach den link benutzen, nehmen wir mal
das, was der chainlord gerade gepostet hat, habt ihr das mitgekriegt von dem wikipedia
build, was massig aufrufe hatte, weil irgendeine indische app das drinne hatte, ah moment,
das ist den asset-image, das will ich ja gar nicht, ich will einfach nur image vom url
oder so, image, network, aha, ok, das ist jetzt schon mal merkwürdig, manchmal braucht
man, manchmal braucht man ein eigenes objekt, jetzt muss man irgendwie, da ist wahrscheinlich
url drinne oder sowas, url, ah Mensch, image, network, platter, google, beste, display image
vom internet, ah yes, im prinzip einfach so, wahrscheinlich einfach, einfach den da, ah
verstehe, ok, sehr gut, bam, nice, q-chat keqw-input, ok, das funktioniert schon mal,
da brauchen wir jetzt natürlich die passende farbe für, blau passt da nicht, was für eine
farbe, purple, was heißt denn rosa, magenta, pink, ah yes, die magenta dna, ok, ok, ok,
so ist es doch nice, cute-app, das ist einfach nur die cute-apps, die cute-app, so, ok, ok,
so, ok, nice, ok, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns zur sache, erstmal, erstmal gleich im
app store hochladen, stadia logo please, warum willst du dir so kack angucken, ach du meinst
in die app, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, ok, der counter macht hier nichts mehr unten,
die floating action buttons können wir einspeck machen, ja so, so viel bessere cute-app, exellente
cute-app, so, was könnte denn die cute-app jetzt tolles machen, sound abspiel, kann flutter,
kann das den sound abspielen, nee, bmi rechne nicht, wir machen die cute-app, oh, ich wollte
eigentlich den ayaya button machen, genau, eigentlich wollte ich den ayaya button machen,
wenn man hier unten draufklickt, dann gibt es den sound, aber es gibt anscheinend keinen
audio player, ich glaube ich hab überhaupt, ich hab hier überhaupt keine, ich hab überhaupt
keine soundcard hier drin, die funktioniert, was ist denn das für ein framework, ein mobile
framework, wie hieß das Ding, was man für alsa mixer nochmal installieren muss, alsa
tools oder sowas, alsa utils 8, erstmal gucken, ob wir überhaupt sounden, der vor allem abspielen
können, master, pcm, wollen wir mal gucken, max fpd, alles klar, sollen wir mal gucken,
ob der jetzt mal in den videos abspielt, nee alsa direkt bam, hört ihr irgendwas, ich
höre nix, aber ich glaube chrome kann alsa direkt ohne puls audio, ne, alter, wir gucken
so ne kacke an, select soundcard, ok, also alsa test, alsa test, da gibt es doch irgendwas,
wenn ich alsa, da kann man doch sound up speaker test was, speaker test, ok geht nicht, doch
ich hab eigentlich ne soundcard drinne, aber die scheinen nicht zu funkt, das ist meine
gecrashed flutter app vom anfang, die ist immer noch da leute, sie lebt noch, bam, ach
leute wisst ihr was auch sein kann, dass im mixer das sound aus ist für die vm, ok leute
ich krieg jetzt in der vm kein sound zum laufen, kann man vergessen mit dem ayaya button, nee
ich n select kein puls audio jetzt, aber zumal puls audio nix bringt, der speaker test mit
alsa direkt müsste auf jeden fall funktionieren, also keine ahnung, ich mein ich hab volle
pulle auf, kann aber alles hoch machen, aber das wirds nicht bringen, ach wisst ihr was
sein kann, dass es die falsche soundcard benutzt, nee nee ich hab nix wegen konsolen beep entfernt
glaub nicht, da würde er ja jetzt auch meckern, ok das krieg ich jetzt nicht gebacken, wundert
mich das so kompliziert ist, weil ich hab in meiner anderen vm hab ich, also die die
ich sonst verwende, wenn ich nicht am stream bin hab ich das eingerichtet, das war eigentlich
relativ easy, warte mal, ist denn windows wenigstens der man das displayed, nee, gott
ne, ok keine ahnung, dann bleib mal bei der cute app ohne sound, ok den button können
wir jetzt zunächst gebrauchen, chat set, ja da kann ich nix machen wenn der chat set
ist, der chat kann mir einfach sagen, was ich noch installieren muss, dass es funktioniert,
der will die vm ge-rebootet haben, nee, brauchen wir nicht, ich bin mir auch nicht mehr sicher
was man machen musste, dass es geht, eigentlich reicht das, brauchst den alsa mixer, machst
sound hoch, ich mach sounddesign wieder aus, falls das hier, er hat ja auch prinzipiell
die soundkarte erkannt, mach use default soundcard, ich hatte doch am anfang default soundcard,
ihr wollt ernsthaft, dass ich reboote, ich spreche kein deutsch, aber schau mir den
stream an, nice, excellent, ok ihr wollt rebooted haben, na dann, wenn der chat das will, wollen
wir mal nicht so sein, power off, ich muss nicht nur rebooten, ich muss ausschalten,
so jetzt, nee wir machen keine wette jetzt, oh, gucken wir mal, wisst ihr was richtig
setge ist, richtig massive setge, dass morgen wieder dienstag ist und wir alle arbeiten gehen
müssen, das ist richtig setge, nee lauter speaker test geht nicht, keine chance,
wow, wow, der speaker test testet, links, rechts, also können wir doch ayaya playen,
ok, was ist das, alter, warum ist denn mein, alter wie fett ist denn mein firefox gerade,
excellent reboot, also bei uns hat es geschneit, aber es ist wieder, wieder alles weg, weiß
ich nicht, wie es bei dir, ok excellent, cute app muss wieder gestartet werden, da können
wir jetzt auch gleich mal lernen, wie man in flutter dependencies hinzufügt, massiv schnee,
ernsthaft, wo kommst du her, bestimmt aus der schweiz in den bergen, irgendwo, ihr wisst
was ich vor zwei tagen getauscht habe, oder am auto, in weiser voraussicht, das ist das
wo ich im stream abgehauen bin zwischendurch, aber ich fahre mit meinem auto eh nicht, wo
kommt die mario musik her, da wo auch der icq sound herkommt, aus deinem lauchtsprecher,
pence champ wirds ich weiß, hier playlist, playlist, so also wie ging das jetzt mit dem
sound player, hier flutter audio player, android, ios, mac os, web, alter was ein sucker player,
der kann kein linux, audio, hast du ein windows notification sound auf dem board, nein hab
ich nicht, wenn ich euch trollen will, wenn ich euch trollen will, wenn ich euch trollen
will, dann mach ich das hier, das ist fies, das ist echt fies, guck hier gerade echt nach
links, fbi, open up, gibt es irgendein paket, was auf linux audio abspielen kann, flutter,
android, ios, mac os, web, flutter sound, android, ios, web, kann man das filtern nach,
ich möchte es gerne, ich will das filtern nach, was unterstützt wird, geht das, anscheinend
nicht, die wichtigste funktion ist wieder nicht dabei oder wie, ich will einfach nur
linux packages, ich kann hier platform linux machen, audio, ok, was auch immer ich da jetzt
gemacht habe, es funktioniert, fügt mal bei der material app noch theme mode dark hinzu,
oh das ist eine gute idee, das machen wir, so, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
nicht jetzt eigentlich dunkel werden funktioniert nicht pro system
Reload umar stimmt vielleicht muss er komplett relauen oder hier drunter
ne okay das funktioniert nicht
das funktioniert nicht mal eine frage bezüglich vm linux möchte gerne auch
beim entwickeln mit linux also erst arbeiten kann ich nur empfehlen aber
strategisiert der hardware als vm sowohl mit proxmox wenn man hyper wie nicht
wirklich performance gelaufen stelle ich mir also ich habe das unter vm wäre es
ist die frage was du für eine für eine grafische oder was für desktop
environment verwendet hast also gnome funktioniert finde ich nicht generell
nicht gut in vm und in theme data brightness die brightness ist da excellent
tag nie also gnome ist nicht so gut also alles was sich auf 3d beschleuniger und
grafikkarte im rechner verlässt ist in der vm jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig voll
die meiste performance also was du machen kannst ist irgendwie die mit
verwenden oder sowas was halt nicht so sehr auf grafikkarte angewiesen ist ich
persönlich stehe ja total auf i3 und du siehst hier die drei kannst du dich
nicht beschweren die drei ist ist poggers schnell wunderbar ich kann ja
auch irgendwie starten oder irgendwie noch ein editor aufmachen also das lebt
bei mir genauso meine expired writer ist genauso lahm wie bei mir auf dem
der preisschirm ist da ist genauso lahm wie auf dem haus das ding ist halt nicht
schnell
kann ich alles machen ich kann auch für die coolen effekte kann doch glx gears
starten huge graphics weiß noch nie gesehen vorher
nicht koggers dreht sich falsch rum
wobei nähe ein stritt sich nicht drum
nähe ich mag dwm auch nicht ich finde es also man kann es mit minimalismus auch
total übertreiben wieviel fps ja anscheinend 60 60 im fullscreen
man muss glaube ich mal man muss man muss doch wie sync ausschalten irgendwie
dass es funktioniert oder macht es das standardmäßig ist er will wie sync
was für ein ding jetzt ist schneller kommt man auch viel flüssiger 6216 fps
huge koggers hyper koggers
was hat ein host system für specs das 8700 k 16 g ram und 1080 ti aber die
grafikkarte macht es wirklich nicht aus in der vm
paar sachen gehen halt in der vm nicht gut zum beispiel 4k youtube videos gucken
weil die eben keine grafikkarten die kauder verwenden können
ich verwende übrigens auch das ein oder andere sackles tool zum beispiel s lock
wer sich jetzt wundert was passiert ist das ding hat den bildschirm gesperrt und
das ist halt ein bildschirm locker der nichts kann außer bildschirm locken und
entlocken aber ja so paar sachen verwende ich von den auch die vm weiß
ich gar nicht muss ich mal kurz gucken was habe ich in der vm gegeben
4 cpu kerne was sie nicht wirklich braucht aber besser haben als brauchen
und 16 g ram bem moment habe ich moment habe ich vielleicht sogar 32 g in meinem
rechner drin habe ich euch miss erzählt ich habe 32 g ich habe 32 g ram ok ich
habe nichts gesagt man kann nie genug haben ja ob 16 oder 32 g habe ich auch
aufgerüstet ich hatte am anfang nur 16 und ich habe mir gedacht 16 ist viel zu
wenig ich brauche 32 jetzt wo ram so billig ist weil wir nichts gefunden wo
man wo man audio unter linux abspielen kann das seht ihr mal das ist das
problem jetzt an flatter und da du kannst halt keine bestehenden libraries
verwenden was was eigentlich ziemlich sagt weil ich mein erster was weiß ich
wie man nur den sound von hand abspielt ich meine ich kann exek machen exek
command flatter packages flatter sound jetzt honigbrei guck mal da steht auch
schon ganz oben flatter android ios web wenn web geht sollte es auch auf linux
gehen aber bin ich mir nicht zu sicher soll ich das mal ausprobieren ja probieren
aus flatter sound wenn der chat das sagt nein nein nein Spaß
das geht im leben nicht unter linux
das geht im leben nicht unter linux das kann man vergessen wir machen exek
immer noch einen ja ja mp3 gepostet oder brauche ich noch mal das da ok
excellent audio play was kann man den kram abspielt ok ich spiele so selten
gibt uns ab ok ff play geht immer ff play geht immer soll das ganz jetzt auch
hitten ff play hin ff play audio no window
what the fuck no exit no display auto exit no display excellent so brauche
mal das so das heißt wenn wir auf den button drücken wenn man auf den button
drücken und pressed floating action button
ja gehackt über die mp3 ja ich dachte es mir schon ich dachte es mir schon
chat chat ist schon schon eingeloggt oder weil geht auch unter linux kann kein
ding
und press das brauche on press ok und press so also flatter exek command
process run import package das ist der moment moment da ist auch da gibt es
auch bestimmt was eingebautes oder das run system command
dat i o make process run import dat i o ok machen wir import da nähe package
package jetzt was da ok da bin ich zu nur mich für wie
funktionieren das jetzt dat i o flatter hier import habe ich doch gemacht
sagt es gibt es nicht
ok was auch immer process start
gucken wir mal ob das an prinzipiell funktioniert process start
ja ja ok es funktioniert es funktioniert also ff play das muss man
wahrscheinlich kompletter fad angeben user bin ff play user bin ff play und
dann das benennen wir mal um ja ja punkt mp3 so und hier so und jetzt
planen wir ja ja ja punkt mp3 ist das problem ja ja ja
ja ja ja mp3 das not contain any stream ach ff play ff play ok ok fast fast ich
brauche ich muss auch argumenten an an dingsen auto exit so cute app ist am
start alle ok man darf nicht zu oft klicken aber es funktioniert das als
weg ja das ist eine gute idee also davon bist auf jeden fall wach kannst du den
sound auch abspielen wenn du aufs bild drückst wenn es noch ein klick wenn es
noch ein klick hat muss man mal gucken hat das noch ein klick klick und klick
und press
flutter und klick image das bild in einen button reppen gesture detector
aber den button sieht wahrscheinlich dumm aus oder an einfachen button gibt
es gar nicht der komme hier mal just gesture gesture detect aller pli
was das für ein trotz
die bade aber sag mal ernsthaft das ist doch irgendwann fünf seiten tief genästet
oder das erkennst du dann gar nicht mehr ok und jetzt kann man hier sagen und
klick und press und long press sie einfach und press und tap es ist ja mobile ok und
tap und tap das da brauche man und tap
funktioniert so die cute app ist finished würde ich sagen und brem flutter das ist
also wir sind nicht und brem wir sind eindeutig in der cloud ja wir verwenden
irgendwelche hardcoded links zu google ok ich habe heute habe ich was gelernt
ja ok jetzt machen wir mal ein bild davon flutter quer que my app bild was ach
mist jetzt in dem moment das stimmt nicht ich hätte das an meine becher zieh
anhängen sollen aber ich brauche wahrscheinlich so oft max was macht die
app die kommt jetzt direkt in play store was kostet was kostet in google was
kostet in play store account wichtigste app überhaupt die cute app 25 euro das
ja nix apple bezahlt glaube ich über 100 euro im jahr na gut deswegen sind die
die app store die apple app store apps im durchschnitt auch besser und nicht ganz
so viel müll drin aber auch viel müll
leute die geht ja gar nicht die app funktioniert ja nur auf dem desktop
weil man ffm pack installiert hat sonst kann er noch nichts abspielen
ich will doch nicht wirklich chat ich will doch nicht wirklich in play store
eintrag für die app jetzt machen lasst euch doch nicht so zutschi bäden
alda ich was ist dafür aber es ist immer ernsthaft
ok guck mal native native cute app am start
und wenn man draufdrückt spielst du den sound ab
gibt es noch diese i am rich app mit dem diamant die nix konnte außer rich zu
sein nein nein nein ich bin handi nicho what the fuck
windows auf windows apps das auch gibt es nicht mehr oder was
i am rich l.a. und platzen pinniger taschen rechnen aus das schlecht
ist das schlecht
ist das schlecht und die leute nehmen das auch noch ernst ist das schlecht
alda kippt am rich android ab gibt es die wege so für android stellt euch mal
vor ihr habt die i am rich app gekauft für google phone nicht cool microsoft
windows phone kostet kostet wie viel kostet denn sie gar nicht bei kann es
sein dass google das google keine preise mehr dahinschreibt außer man ist am
man ist am handi ja ich akzeptier alles
na gut leute wir haben es geschafft wir haben die cute app am start es macht die
app die hatten einen button man kann was reinschreiben und es macht den sound
wenn man draufklickt beste app und dafür ist das ganze jetzt haltet euch mal fest
und dafür ist die app nur 56 mb groß und braucht nur mal kurz hier haben wir
kurz alles zu was noch oft war und braucht nur nur 36 mb ram das geht doch
voll klar das geht doch voll klar elektron hat jetzt erst mal 54 mb
ram gefressen und und 15 chromium threads gestartet
der mag nicht so viele sachen starten beste app überhaupt jetzt es wird zeit
leute ich würde sagen zeit start-up zu gründen oder
ok die gibt den ram nicht wieder frei
wieso ist das weniger wollen wir das letzte mal was die back jetzt ist es der
richtige bild
ja ja ja es ist service ja ich finde auch cute chat limited was haltet ihr
davon cute chat ltd wie das gibt schon
cute chat moment warum gibt es so viele projekte die github gibt auf github
was was cute hat heißt cute chat
what the fuck was auch cute chat hat keine issues
ja kann ich verstehen java rups leute ich bin begeistert meine erste flatte app
ist es nicht geil exquisite ja richtige also für die erste flatte app hier ich
fasse es nicht meine erste flatte app die cute app eigentlich richtig sinnlos
ja nice ok chat wir machen mal kurz hier genug flatter gebastelt für heute das
neue instagram instagram wer will instagram neue clubhouse instagram ist
schon laut da schau es genau stimmt das gibt es ja schon das gibt es ja schon
wobei es muss eigentlich eigentlich müsste es meinem alter angemessen sein
und meinem alter angemessen wäre das eher das nächste facebook weil die leute in
meinem alter sind alle auf facebook und fühlen sich geil und machen da boomer
witz ich bin nicht cloud native wenn ich ins wenn ich nicht instagram sage ich
sage ja auch schon jubantu und emerson das sollte eigentlich reichen und
gyra und jit und jit facebook hey leute in meinem alter verwenden immer noch
facebook ich kann es nicht verstehen weil ich habe nie facebook verwendet
doch wobei ich habe ich habe eine max fps seite auf auf facebook weil die
leute früher facebook verwendet haben aber ich habe da seit drei jahre nichts
mehr gepostet das ist das ist wo ich mich über die die
gamescom-aktion lustig gemacht habe und das war die reffling gepostet 2015 finger
liegt auf facebook
das hat deutlich mehr likes das stimmt ja einfach nicht das hatte 800 oder
sonst war es ihr guckt mal das gebetet gibt es den noch schon eine weile nichts
mehr gehören 2017 keck weight
ich werde jetzt auch computer futzi easy 300 leute haben einfach den facebook
account gelöscht das oder es war nicht 800 ist auch egal facebook juckt mich
also ich muss sagen facebook habe ich nur gemacht weil die leute es damals hatten
nicht weil ich facebook irgendwie gut fand übrigens auf facebook steht eine
sache die stimmt überhaupt nicht und zwar auf facebook steht ich wäre
angeblich angeblich bin ich sponsort bei alien wehr das stimmt überhaupt nicht
ich wollte mal verurzeiten was machen mit alien wehr ich glaube das habe ich
damals als demo reingemacht so könnte man das machen aber wir haben da nie was
zusammen gemacht gibt es ihn eigentlich noch der ist auch mal der ist auch mal
auf twitch gewesen und dann habe ich nie mal was von ihm gesehen
verklagen was soll ich verklagen
du musst dann bei link das ist korrekt das ist korrekt das mache ich dann beim
nächsten stellen aus stellen anzeigen video dann suche ich als flatter app
programmieren mal den job leute weißt du was man echt ohne scheiß wisst ihr was
man machen müsste den link in account erstellen reinschreiben flatter flatter
kenntnisse und du suchst job als flatter entwicklung und als referenz und als
referenz machen wir die cute app rein und dann meint ihr meint ihr da melden
sich irgendwelche headhunter 100 pro oder die schreiben doch eh random einfach
nur leute an ohne sich das genauer anzugucken ich schreibe rein 15 jahre 15
jahre flatter enterprise business experience als chief flatter technology
engineer programmer engineer und dann gebe ich als referenz gebe ich meine
app an 30 jahre flatter mein 15 jahre reichen nicht und ich meine ihr müsst
euch mal angucken was für ein geiles feature was für ein geiles feature man
kann man kann auf den button klicken für den sound und man kann auf das bild
klicken für den sound also es ist besser als vlc schon mal und es ist responsive
so halbwegs zumindest also ich finde es ist schon eindeutig besser als vlc
wobei vlc verwenden die coolen die coolen leute auf linkedin nicht besser
als apple music
wusste die eigentlich dass die sounds in apple betriebssystem früher total
viele beetles referenzen hatten nur um anwälte abzufacken
habe ich letztens in video drüber gelesen ich lese auch videos kein
problem habe ich letztens in video drüber gesehen
weil apple musste damals sagen sie gehen nie ins musikbusiness weil weil das
platten label der beetles wohl apple hieß und apple hat gesagt sie machen
nix musik mäßiges und um die anwälte abzufacken haben sie dann die ganzen
sounds und der den alten mac os betriebssystem irgendwelche referenzen
auf beetle songs gemacht um die anwälte zu ärgern
letztes video gelesen ja
aber warum ging es jetzt nicht kein cloud native button
wo wir wieder dabei sind wenn es kompiliert dann geht es offensichtlich
na ja ja das ist das ist aber auch von 2006 das ist ja schon relativ relativ
neu läuft wieder komplett ich habe ehrlich gesagt keinen schimmer ich habe
o v h nix und wisst ihr warum ich bei o v h nix habe ich versuche es euch mal zu
zeigen kurz ich wollte mir bei o v h was mieten
ja ich wollte mir bei o v h was mieten
und o v h hat gesagt
okay die sind vielleicht immer noch daun
ja anscheinend wollen die das jetzt gar nicht mehr weiter wissen
o vor hat gesagt ich soll meinen ausweis kopieren und ihn schicken für den
popelischen zwei euro v v v m und da habe ich gesagt ne mache ich nicht
und deswegen habe ich und deswegen läuft der preis champ nicht bei o v h
na ja na ja ich sag mal so also offiziell ja inoffiziell musst du das nicht das
habe ich gehört ja und ich habe mich wieder gefragt warum lassen leute das
ihr ihr ihr lokales netzwerkequipment über die cloud managen ist das nicht
komplett kontraproduktiv irgendwie warum macht man so was nein es ist auch bei
alten youtube accounts also wenn in den youtube video habt was ab 18 ist macht
es einfach mit vlc auf oder mit irgendwas anderem dann geht das auch das
müsst ihr nicht über youtube gucken und dann müsst ihr euch auch nicht anmelden
und dann müsst ihr auch keine keine kein personalausweis angeben aber
offiziell muss man das dann oder youtube die l downloaden ja man nennt es doch
umgangssprachlich root server gar nicht
close source huge dogs cute chat limited in england am start also ich bin bei ich
bin bei allem mittlerweile bei hetzner und ich finde die vom preis her echt in
ordnung
ja aber wie gesagt warum warum die warum man seinen netzwerk management für
lokale netzwerkequipment gear über die cloud laufen lässt ist es entzieht sich
komplett meinem verständnis ja also ich mag hetzner allein schon nachdem das
andere ab et cetera abgeraucht ist mehr ova hat wohl ergeblich eine super
den aus protection kann ich nix zu sagen das video mache ich jetzt nicht auf ich
weiß nicht was der sache ist
ja einfach klaut flair kommt drauf an die einfache die einfache den aus
protection von klaut flair macht halt auch kein magic und viele zusatzfunktion
bei klaut flair musste musste zusätzlich kaufen also wir haben es
letztes mal getestet also mit mit jemand aus dem stream der zugriff auf so ein
paar zehntausende polenrechner oder so hatte keine ahnung wo das her her
gekommen ist und das ist einfach ratz patz durch klaut flair durch und hat
das ding lahm gelegt im preis champ aber das lag halt daran das waren legit
anfragen und ich hätte in klaut flair auf attack schalten können das hätte
funktioniert wahrscheinlich ja aber das muss ich ja manuell machen und ova hat
er angeblich super ausgeklügelten schutz gegen so was habe ich aber noch
nicht ausprobiert und sie müssen zumindest ein ziemlich fettes netz
anbindung haben und ordentlich fettes netzwerke equipment dass das ein das
einiges ab kann also das würde ich sagen wäre es mal wert aus prob ausprobiert
zu werden aber ich sehe es nicht ein jetzt zu
ova zu wechseln ich weiß nicht was der hatte ich will es auch gar nicht zu
genau wissen ehrlich gesagt
was bezieht sich das jetzt ach so du meinst die leute die youtube ja gut die
haben halt pesh die haben halt pesh
ja das ist in spanische seite unter italienisch verstehe dann nur die
hälfte sind bilder sind bilder vom ova rechenzentrum oder so was mit was auch
immer ich da sehe das ist das rz das abgebrannt ist ja anscheinend war nicht
genug brand protection ja ja gut mit wasser kommt man da eh nicht weit und
außerdem naja der boden ist auch geil aber was das für ein boden ist das
wolle oder ist holz ja kann das kann letztendlich mehr oder weniger jedem
anbieter mal passieren du musst immer abwiegen du musst immer abwiegen
abwiegen zwischen wie viel kosts und und wie also was lässt es dir kosten dein
schlechtes bauchgefühl zu beseitigen ja also ja letztendlich kann das schon
verstehen dass da so weit gekommen ist nachher kann man immer meckern
klar aber auf der anderen seite guck mal wenn sie es teurer gebaut hätten
hätte man sich da vielleicht gar keine surfer gekauft weil sie teuer ist also
das ist immer so immer so hin und her das kann dir letztendlich mit fast
jedem anbieter passieren dass da irgendwas so verkackt wird dass die
kisten weg sind pech gehabt deswegen sollte man sich halt noch nicht auf eine
kiste an einem standort verlassen
übrigens rechenzentrum mit teppich boden da kenne ich auch was da könnte ich
mal ein video drüber machen eigentlich rechenzentrum mit teppich boden
genau also ich kenne das auch rechenzentrum mit teppich boden und zwar
als ich noch da wo ich die ausbildung beim provider gemacht habe da gearbeitet
habe die haben für für eine stadt haben die den it service zeug mit gemacht und
dass sie in der nähe storage und server aufstellen konnten haben die sich
einfach eine wohnung gemietet und haben dort rechse eingestellt mitten in die
wohnung da war teppich im rechenzentrum und das
system wurde mit dem kran durchs fenster reingehoben hat glaube ich noch die
fenster bahn kaputt gemacht dabei
das hat wunderbar funktioniert
so ist das halt als computer futsi ja
so leute ich gehe jetzt auf und morgen muss ich wieder aber da habe ich keinen
bock drauf aber so ist es halt wir sehen uns macht's gut bis denn